a wall a warm welcome to all of you
joining the second day of the omics
research symposium
today to those who are joining for the
first time
my name is mohit mazumdar and i have a
phd in computational biology and along
with a great team
i'm heading the global business
development and omics logic in asia
in this introductory session we will
start with the recap of day one and it
will it will be also a great opportunity
for those who could not join the
sessions yesterday our team is already
working on the session recordings and
they will be soon available and will be
posted on our social media and youtube
channel so stay tuned and also subscribe
on the youtube channel to get
notification about the videos
so as the nalika already described what
we did and i think we did a lot as i'm
as i was saying that there was so much
to learn yesterday from the experts from
academia and research institutes about
bioinformatics and and its data-driven
uh science and machine learning why
machine learning is hyped and
and we talked about and saw the
application so we learned about
applications we learned from case
studies and discussions on how to be
trained uh how to be trained uh get
trained and uh what is the future of
this field
so uh
in today's session as i said that we
will start with a recap to so to start
with that uh
yesterday we had mr nalika like always
started with the omixlogic global portal
and describing how we see bioinformatics
describing how what are the different
bioinformatics training challenges that
are related to this tremendous growth in
this field enormous computational power
requirements lack of coding knowledge
faculties lacking the
required facilities and uh the structure
so uh sonalika explained how omixlogic
addresses these by standardization
organization and systematization
applying bloom's taxonomy levels seeing
biology as data science and employing
the hybrid learning approach
so followed by which uh the session by
sunan lika was followed by the
introduction of hdinit initiative which
i did and the team responsible for daily
interaction and development of resources
and collaborations across asia pacific
and
then we discussed about that with the
help of our international collaborators
partners benefiting from this community
and we announced the
partnership program partnership
university program yesterday the
partnership university university
program is designed for the university
partner to benefit from the
collaborative association with pine
biotec and their partners so this
special program is designed by utilizing
the best of resources which are hosted
at learnomexlogic.com
includes the coursework project based
training for beginners intermediate and
advanced users helping them achieve the
objectives of bioinformatics or
omixologic data science and
bioinformatics research training
the omics logic partnership program
which we described in much more detail
we described that it follows a unique
curriculum designed for personalized
training and research experience that
enables the participants to develop
critical scientific thinking utilizing
modern bioinformatics and data science
practices on industry relevant problems
so the omixlogic program for university
also follows the in-depth structure
which we went through by looking at one
of the case studies
where we describe the different stages
and resources the stages include basic
training example projects and boarding
preparing preparing to work on a project
by practicing on various data sets and
algorithms and finally to be able to
work on on your own research project or
a faculty driven project so we piloted
our pro mix logic training with several
universities and we showcased a recent
program as a case study that clearly
highlights the effectiveness and the
impact of the pro of the program
now this case study that we highlighted
yesterday was about the collaboration
and the partnership hello everyone my
name is
okay i'm a final year student person
there's a video presentation which got
played but what i was saying that this
collaboration and the partnership
allowed students to work on their topics
and interest and do real research on
noble projects which were curated by
mentors and experts
and also as well as for the su for the
students
for the students
to improve their ranking in college and
get an impressive resume that highlights
their achievement
and for those students
such as your aditya
who has a research interest to work on
several projects and to contribute to
the scientific community and as well as
by working hello by working on pressing
challenges that had made the society
dysfunctional such as scored 19 and had
had a huge impact on uh well-being
this was said also by dr vishan gupta
the next keynote speaker
who started describing about the
collaboration with ames new delhi
and his work which explained like how
what is the importance of uh indian
cohorts
while studying the kovic 19 or while
doing the kobe 19 research and then
covet 19 which left so many people dead
had no molecular data especially from
the indian cohorts covet patients have
it it got concluded to the fact that the
covet patients have lung microbiome
dysbiosis the the lung microbiome
distinguishes between
patient types so that's a way to
distinguish between patient types
leading to the suggestion of you know
patient stratification so it was a very
important topic and research that was
highlighted by doctor ishan gupta
followed by the dr suchin agar who
talked about various courses which are
offered by uh the university uh dy
partly university and discussed genomics
transcriptomics proteomics metabolomics
what is omics what are the branches of
omics and the process of bioinformatics
analysis so there was a lot of emphasis
on the workflows which showed the basic
tools also like blast eugene mega uh
then finding out variation then find
what do what are the application in the
uh in of genomics and transcriptomics in
different
fields such as molecular medicine
microbial genomics
risk assess assessments uh micro uh
bioarchaeology anthropology uh human
migration so this huge huge application
that we learned that from dna
identification to you know add
agriculture to live life live stock
livestock breeding and bioprocesses so i
think the application that we learned
from this talk was really helpful and
also the pathways i mean it's very
useful for the students to know about
this and maybe choose a direction
and that was followed by a great talk
again by dr anju bharathwaj who was
talking about genomics and its
application and the current places and
the shape it is taking so she
highlighted about the human genome
project the global interest to
understand human genome human diseases
and understand the genomic variations
what are the single and nucleotide
polymorphisms what what were the
candidates genomic approaches and
genome-wide association studies and the
global effort to catalog the genomic
variation she also shared a lot of
resources which i thought would be would
have been very much helpful and
as as i said that these sessions will
also be um will also be posted online
then we had that very interesting uh um
educational panel discussion where we
discussed about the new educational
policy in india and their the actual
need for data science education and got
to know about from the experts that uh
how we can have data science education
uh being imparted to students through
basic training and a project-based
learning and then we discussed about the
new education policy and how it
encourages the uh
hybrid learning and what are the
challenges that the universities faced
while doing the hybrid learning and what
are the what are the main
taking away points positive points and
how that has led to a hybrid setting of
education which is very very um
effective
uh then we discussed about some of the
promising areas where bioinformatics is
needed in asia and india and also with
the respect of academic like stand
points academic uh experts so job
opportunities in academia and what are
the different ways to do and go about
this doing a masters or phd and all of
those questions were answered and
discussed in detail in the session
followed by that we had a very very
interesting poster presentation
competition that covered
omics and bioinformatics artificial
intelligence machine learning
astrobiology space omix computational
biology and pharmaceutical industries so
students where
we're showcasing their work and that
we're from various
backgrounds and from various research
areas and that kind of concluded the
first part of this uh
day one and then we had different panels
after the asia panel we moved to the
african panel and we learned from the
panel where we learned about the
omics logic african programs
partnerships and outcomes discusses by
ayan faye and eddie conley where we
learned about the bioinformatics tools
and resources that have been provided
the data science for biologist program
and then discussion about the discussion
with the panel about all of these
different topics where
we discussed about scaling
bioinformatics education and training
and what are the future opportunities
and how bioinformation is evolving in
africa considering that it has such a
diversity in its genomic makeup
considering the number of infectious
diseases and also the clinical
uh clinical information that we get from
africa is much more structured than in
india so this is where some of the
things that were highlighted and then
from the african
panel we moved to the us panel where mr
brodsky ceo
highlighted that what are the advances
in this in enabling technologies and
then how bioinformatics and these events
such as hackathon and then the
understanding of how bioinformatics is
applied in wellness and health then how
to build a team
build an application publish and share
initiatives he discussed about our
initiatives in the us he discussed about
the virtual programs that we did and
also the research fellowship program and
our participation in tech cup leading to
the semi-finalist position and now we
are moving towards that competition in
the next in this coming month
so that was uh the introduction and
start to the us session and we had
follow-up
important talks on scientific topics
which i think interested you uh many of
you a lot and though for those who are
joining for the second day
we have many interesting talks and
industry input coming up and i think it
will be another very interesting and
informative day for those who all are
joining so again thank you all for
joining today's session uh we are going
through a recap of what we did uh on day
one and uh after the indian panel and
after the african panel and the
introduction to the u.s dr nikolai uh
started with a senior bioinformatician
at the department of biology during
university sweden um talked about the
machine learning view of multi-omics
data integration he was discussing about
the multi-mix integration across you
know across several features and several
samples he discussed about the hidden
patterns in individual omics and then he
discussed about the curse of
dimensionality and also gave practical
example from from his lab from his work
and uh to get an idea and work
and know what they do
that was followed by another interesting
talk which was focused on
bioinformatics application so
uh what we imagine for future
uh is these dashboards and these
dashboards will give momentum and prove
to be an excellent instrument for
sharing biological data sets together
with results that is what uh dr julia
panoff concluded with but she discussed
about dashboard integration a very
important aspect of cloud computing and
uh doing this um and developing these
dashboards which are like pipelines
which get answers which give answers to
specific biological problems so just you
discussed about the easy data
visualization and interaction how it
could be shared allow easy navigation
and analysis of different models
exploring ways to add code for r and
python so these are some of the
important aspects she discussed and i
think it was a great session uh followed
by the session by elisa vetta she is the
research associated associate at the top
research by from topper bioinformatics
research center and she discussed about
the analysis of metagenomic data on
tbinfo platform where she described
about the crime tool that used to ana
that uses that we use to analyst and
analyze the metagenomic data and which
is now uh available on tv and for
platform and gave an overview of
metagenomics how can you upload files
how can you run algorithms and how can
you
design those pipelines and out get
outputs
and then understand by visualization and
again the incorporation of dashboards so
this was from topper tower group
describing about the advancements that
have come up in the tibet info platform
followed by that
we had uh the session which was about
the forensic sciences like how omics is
now used in forensic sciences so sara dr
sarah
she worked on interdisciplinary foreign
sciences and integration of omics
technology she told us how the future
research will be able to expand on these
current studies hoping for a lead
leading to a wider implication of
performance technology in forensic
sciences where she discussed about the
application of genomics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolomics for
forensics and what is str profiling
which is the short tandem repeat
profiling for
identification of victims or
perpetrators and then what is foreign
dna
phenotyping and then there were a lot of
keywords which were
which would be really interesting for
those who are interested in forensic
sciences and understanding that from
soil microbiome to all this omics data
how it is helping in investigation of uh
irony here india's crimes and sometimes
uh other
applications as well
now uh after this initial discussion and
all of the
all of the uh keynote speakers uh
we had lucas um who is an undergraduate
student of statistics and his
representative of omixlogic team in
latin america uh talked about his
opening remarks in his opening remarks
talked about bioinformatics education in
brazil and introduced introducing the
bioinformatics
training and how we are working on
different courses which are now
translated in portuguese and will be
available and is available for students
who are
more comfortable in the native language
followed by that uh introduction we had
the speaker
of dr luis sukamuto who is who talked
about the precision medicine in brazil
so
uh the reality and the trends and he's a
precision medicine patriot he's a
patriotic oncologist described about the
patriotic cancer and frequency in
frequency in children the survival rate
the importance of childhood cancer for
health system and then what are the
molecular classes what are the ways to
do the molecular classification
what are the actionable targets uh using
evidence-based somatic variation and
also shared clinical cases
then uh we had this session about system
biology as sonalika was saying that we
had so many different sessions from
different uh different research areas uh
where dr kasturi kanan who is an
associate professor at translational
molecular pathology
discussed about bioinformatics and
cancer system biology so system biologic
biology initiatives for brain tumor how
there is a unified goal to create a
computational framework to integrate all
available patient centric brain tumor
recurrence data to generate uh to
generate these hypothesis which is more
unbiased in nature because of the entire
incorporation of data for actionable
target validation and for predicting
diseases outcome for initial clinical
trials
so
all of this was concluded with this
uh with this panel discussion uh which
kind of summarized this that how to
apply these technologies to solve
challenges as we saw in the case of sara
and then from nikolai
from physics to life sciences how he got
fascinated and
by physicians and clinicians to mind
more knowledge and how dr kasturi talked
about his journey and he got curious and
get
self-taught bioinformatics and talked
about what are the skill sets that are
required by students coding databases
and all of the tools that we are seeing
is something that
elia discussed and this was again one of
the sessions where we concluded all of
this and
we discussed about uh
how interdisciplinary fields are
integrated with multi strategy to evolve
students in bioinformatics and data
science which is the future of
future of
future of healthcare and well-being so
from this uh this was the recap of day
one and i hope that this recap is
helpful for those who who could not join
uh yesterday or who could not complete
all the sessions as we had nine years or
nine hours of intensive uh talks and
sessions for uh students from our global
community joining from india joining
from asia joining from africa
joining from europe and the us and latin
america
so um i'm really excited that we had
such a wonderful wonderful time
yesterday and uh now really hoping that
uh
after this quick recap uh we are back
with yet another day and today we will
hear uh hear about the prospectives of
different researchers and indian
industry experts from us and india and
africa so today
we we kind of highlighted of some of our
collaborators and
industry collaborators many of them
would be
available today to help the
viewers or the participants to learn
about what is what are the advancements
in the are in the industry
how to how do you get into these
different uh careers and what are the
opportunities
uh combining what we did with an
industry within academia and now
learning from an industry perspective uh
is a great great way to go about
the
depth of
where this is heading and to you know be
prepared
so
today we will listen to our great
panelists who are industry professionals
from nep as sonalika has already
described what we are going to do an and
give an overview so nepi and its network
universities and institutions as well as
industry partners such as faba and
bioinformatics companies such as uc data
as well as engineers companies such as
primary life sciences to application
driven companies such as on phenomics
and eq mind and maintenance hype who are
helping students transition to industry
will be some of the
some of the uh the speakers and keynote
uh panelists so let's quickly take a
look at what we are expecting and what
what what kind of sessions that we will
be having so we will have of our first
session in in very in in few minutes
perhaps with uh with dr g sarkar who is
a physician scientist and would be
talking about clinical informatics and
use cases and challenges we are really
looking forward to the session because
you would be able to understand how
clinical informatics is being applied in
industry and what are the opportunities
as well similarly then we go from there
to dr shibi uh shibu chakrabhatikanan
who is an entrepreneur as well as a
scientist
working on so many different cancer
therapies almost the cutting-edge
technologies that are being used
worldwide and uh we're working from uh
from india and bringing some of these
technologies and uh research in india so
it will be something that will be a
great session for all of those who are
interested in cancer research
then we have dr nidhi quran
from faba who are who are very close
collaborators in india located in
hyderabad and the network
that father represents all the
biotechnology industry and academia
where she will be talking about uh the
different opportunities that far back
academy is bringing and how our
collaborative work is also helping a lot
of students and also universities to
develop these programs
where they can
you know in where they can kind of
bridge this missing link link between
academy and industry that would help
actually a lot of students transition
from academia to industry
without the struggles that we usually
see students and
through our own experience right now
after that we have again a very
interesting industry panel discussion
and that industry panel discussion will
focus on uh some of these topics that
you can see on the screen that would
tell us about the future of indian
healthcare sector how bioinformatics in
industry is different from academia
like uh the questions that we you would
want to ask is that how to prepare from
a from for a for a job that you have
thought of that you have dreamt of uh of
in a company without the stated
experience what are the key points that
recruiters notice in a cv so there are a
lot of opportunities to learn from these
academic experts and ask your questions
and we will be looking forward to to
answer some of your questions as well as
the questions that we have prepared for
the panel discussion that will be
followed by some of these important
skill sets and we have been discussing
about the participation of industry and
the skill sets so doctor rajasthan will
be talking about that and then we have
session from uh miss
patimoyo from africa talking about the
diplomas and cpgr grant program and then
we have the
uh like more of a
specialized sessions which is for a
larger audience who are interested in
protein protein interaction and how
these uh grafted peptides are used as
strategy and then bioinformatics in
beauty industry are very
um inspiring kind of a talk and we are
looking forward to learn actually it's
this new for many of us that how
bioinformatics is used in beauty
industry what are the applications and
then uh
learn from speakers from university of
malta
about the life science research in space
so how life sciences research in space
is uh
being done through
dr joseph bohr who is an associate
professor and principal investigator
and uh also working on single cell so
then we have the price distribution
ceremony for that from the students who
presented and submitted their posters
and then we have sessions by the nappy
uh neppy founders and neppy uh directors
uh so dr guskas phillips director
of the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine biomed and a renowned
professor of virology will be talking
about
the nappy idea program and
then we have uh ilya brodsky who will be
also describing the our efforts with
nepi network and how what are the
different expectations and outcomes that
we have seen and then we have some
specialized sessions again which is to
understanding of viruses and microbial
microbes so these are for those students
are for those who are interested in
infectious disease research then we have
uh machine learning uh where all of this
research is being utilized further to
develop models to develop uh models that
could be predictive in nature then we
have uh from bench to a computer where
we are discussing about application in
cancer therapy by doctor immunology uh
from the lsu school of veterinary
medicine and then we have the panel
discussion for nepi which will conclude
the day two and uh where we will learn
about the different aspects of how to
improve
uh the training that is across 23 states
and puerto rico so i think we are really
really excited for all of these upcoming
sessions and i hope that all of you who
have joined us today and will be joining
us throughout this event uh we'll be
able to learn and we'll be able to ask
and we'll be able to experience uh the
the discussions and the talks from our
uh from our respected experts and
dignitaries